I'm going to the frontlines tomorrow by
which I mean the terrifying living room
of a DC area high schooler who is
housing students coming in for the March
this will be a gigantic
once-in-a-lifetime television event but
you won't find me promoting it like CNN
with some garish countdown clock in the
lower right hand corner of the screen
ours is going to be in the left hand
corner
we're not jerks and since these students
began their campaign to save lives
my fellow right-wingers have taken the
only appropriate stance against and
they're not afraid to ask the right
questions like since when canteens
organize you see Fox pundit and woman
who's tried falafel once and only once
laura ingraham knows the truth i'm gonna
figure out how i can be away this
weekend because a half million
protesters are expected to descend on
washington to push for more gun control
and school safety hundreds of other
protests are planned around the world on
the same day and we're told that each
March is basically student-led but did
students really organize all of this and
the five weeks since the Florida
shooting yes yeah five weeks that's
barely a month
think about what it takes to put
together a March they have to get there
they have to March
that would take years of planning high
schoolers couldn't possibly have the
communication skills to pull this off
all they do all day is mess around on
their phones create Facebook events
establish personal brands and invent
complex layers of internet culture that
I will never understand dumb kids I have
just one question though who's helping
them George Clooney and his wife and his
two children are coming because he wrote
a check Oprah Winfrey donated half a
million dollars so did Steven Spielberg
Jeffrey Katzenberg so there's certainly
a lot of nieces they're all back yeah
the cleanest us a name that applies both
Clinton and foreign the two worst
enemies of America opposition this is
what the left does they hold these giant
marches demanding change with passionate
voices that are totally fake because
George Clooney paid for the
porta-potties